sometimes mysterious sometimes painful
almost always embarrassing take heed of
this warning these stories of my
co-workers will put fear in your heart
and may make you never use Facebook
again these are social media horror
stories my name is Ari I'm 26 and I had
a traumatic social media occurrence just
as last weekend I have a friend that
thought me and her roommate would be
cute she sent me his Instagram story it
was a nice Instagram story it's like him
playing the guitar and I responded to
her nice vibe but not super into the
face what I didn't realize is that I had
actually direct messaged him that and
not her her I was like oh damn like I
can't believe I said that to him I was a
backpedaling and I was like oh sorry
didn't mean to send that you have a
great face and then he responded ha
exclamation part bangs question mark I
feel like this was a good lesson to be
really sure that you're sending the
message to who you think your session
yes you know
[Music]
when I was in college a few years ago I
went to New York City to visit a friend
and we went out to a club and we were
drinking but then we came back to my
friend's place and I was very very drunk
and I decided that it would be a great
idea to send someone to dick pic so took
a picture of my penis and I think I'm
sending it to this person so I went to
bed and I woke up to realize that this
picture of didn't go to the person I
sent it to it went to my story on
snapchat I deleted the picture
immediately I looked at how many people
saw it and it was only like 30-something
views and like two screenshots I was in
the East Coast which is a few hours
ahead so when I posted the picture all
my friends were asleep and when I
deleted it they were probably asleep I
don't know who screenshot it I deleted
it right away but whoever did screenshot
it you're a garbage person and ever
since there's no naked pictures of me
anywhere I don't send them I don't mail
them I don't email them I was just drunk
and I felt adventurous and lesson
learned never again
so my social media horror story comes
from college in fact the last day of
college I wanted to celebrate my last
paper of my college career so I hold out
my paper like this I take a photo of it
from back here and post that photo to
Instagram being the senioritis Spring
Quarter senior that I was I decided to
take a creative writing class and so I
decided to make a really creative story
for my final story for that class and
that was quite risque and I get right
into it on the first page I uploaded the
diss photo to Instagram thinking nothing
of it people just see a paper with text
on it then the comments start flooding
it about how interesting my story is to
give you an idea of what was on that
first page I just like to read you a
couple of excerpts i J was stressed out
however he could feel his dick start to
harden with his left hand he fiddled
with the buckle on his belt while
simultaneously craning his right hand to
type pornhub.com into the browser's
address bar I did write a story about a
guy watching porn and then artificial
intelligence coming from it and I had to
explain why I had a sudden a fascination
with sex things
[Music]